so let's talk about the tactics of
searching for a job today some of the
tactics are quite different but some of
the principles are absolutely timeless
some of the tactics that are different
LinkedIn LinkedIn is an essential
resource for potential employees and
employers it is the de facto global
standard for four hundred million people
in business part of the reason why
Microsoft paid twenty six point two
billion dollars for the global LinkedIn
network but LinkedIn is a really
essential thing to do and filling in and
completing a good LinkedIn profile is an
essential step you want to have a really
good professional but personable picture
on it because pictures are more valuable
than all the words and then you want to
have the equivalent of a top-level
resume in all your affiliations your
your your titles your interest so the
LinkedIn profile is key most likely
that's not going to be how you get a job
but when you're in a job conversation
employers will refer automatically to
your LinkedIn profile so that's really
important before you do a LinkedIn
profile it's important to develop a
resume coming out of college you
generally want to have your resume on
one page all the resume basics there's
millions of things written about resumes
but I will tell you one thing I probably
evaluated 20,000 resumes over the last
25 years here's how people read resumes
they look at your name and the mindset
is do I know her or him or not and where
it where are they based then they
quickly look to the bottom of the page
and they look at the personal things and
this is where it's really in your power
to differentiate yourself you don't want
to say capable at Microsoft Word and
Excel and PowerPoint the Adobe suite of
Photoshop things that's fine but that's
the place where you want to say
completed the world triathlon
championship or
hiked Machu Picchu or enjoy cooking and
specialize in Mexican tequila recipes
traveled to what are very very specific
things member of the League of Women
Voters if you're a guy it creates a
little bit of a question that's a real
entre into the into the conversation and
employers are looking to start a
conversation to say oh you had three
holes in one and golf how did that
happen and you're talking the bottom of
your resume so so that's the next thing
and then the basics what the company or
the organization or this education is
the year a couple of the quantifiable
basics internships and it's okay
especially if you're coming out of
college to be totally real your mowed
lawns for the summer or you busting out
and uh in a restaurant all of those
things which as as actually someone in
their 20s you might think oh god I
didn't learn anything I didn't do
anything but employers are looking for
those real life skills to show work
ethic and initiative and they respect
that if your camp counselor that's fine
too but talk about what the experience
you gained you know being responsible
for a bunk of seven year old girls
anyway it's okay to be yourself and put
that in in the kind of context so have a
resume and doing after the resume it's
easier to create your link LinkedIn
profile from that it used to be that
resumes were sent with cover letters
through the mail they would get opened
or not and they would get filed it's
important to know that most resumes
certainly will be read as a first-time
if they're read at all they'll be open
most likely on a mobile device so the
layout is really important and if you're
writing to an HR leader or Human
Resources later you know maybe they'll
be reading it in their office but
they'll be transmitted electronically so
the principles of a cover letter are a
transmittal email and an email
is not a text but an email is not a
formal letter either so it's somewhere
in between it's got to be professional
make sure to have no grammatical errors
in your resume or on your transmittal
email so those are those are basics but
here's the thing over two-thirds of jobs
are gotten through referrals they're not
gotten by applying cold to an
organization it's really frustrating for
people I know this to like look at a
employment site going to the jobs
listings about us and it says submit
your application submit your resume your
LinkedIn profile and a cover letter and
you do that and it feels like you're
putting your personal materials into a
black hole many great companies find a
way to have the systems to get back to
you but most don't it's just hard
because they get too many in bounds but
here's the thing most most positions are
filled before they ever go to be
listings and sometimes companies feel
the need or for legal reasons that they
have to list them 2/3 of the jobs are
gotten through referrals so with that in
mind and having done your basics of a
good LinkedIn profile in a resume here's
the way to activate that and this is a
timeless principle about job searching
at the entry level all the way up to the
CEO suite its recommendations by your
friends or your friends of friends and I
often get asked what is the single best
piece of job search advice I have and
here's what I say have a crisp answer to
the question so what do you want to do
especially people coming out of college
they're sometimes surprised by that
question and they're like the worst
answer is I don't know the second worst
answer is I'll do anything you want to
be able to help people help you
and so you want to have a one-sentence
answer to that question of what you want
to do that make sense and give someone
enough ammunition so that when they hear
that there's an opening at the American
Red Cross it's like oh I just met this
really talented young woman who's coming
out of Johns Hopkins University who is
dedicated to helping on disaster relief
and she wants to work at the American
Red Cross
maybe it's your your aunt who you
mentioned that too at the Father's Day
picnic you never know where it's going
to come from so I like to think that
it's like planting seeds on the wind and
sometimes they'll land and they'll get
their fill grow roots so have your one
sentence answer and anything is fine but
you really need to say I've always loved
the financial markets I want to get an
entry-level position on Wall Street I'm
interested in government I majored in
political science and I want to break in
with a legislative internship I'm really
passionate about protecting the
environment so I want to find a
not-for-profit dedicated to prevent
global warming
I love gender equality I'm looking for a
company that is really focused on
empowering women whatever it is have the
answer to that and then say that to as
many people as you can and you'll be
shocked at when it comes from and this
is where it pays to mention that to your
professors to your parents to the
friends of your parents and to your
friends and most of this will come back
and then your LinkedIn profile and your
resume will get kicked in but unless you
give someone the tool to say I'm looking
to break into online video production
nobody will come back and and ask you
that so I know that's my single best
piece of job search advice